-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actress
you know from her work
on "Dawson's Creek"
and films like "Batman Begins"
and "All We Had."
She produced, wrote, directed
and stars in "Alone Together"
which is in select theaters this
Friday and On Demand July 29th.
Let's take a look.
-This is, um,
34 Cherry Lane, right?
-34, yeah.
Yeah, it is.
-My boyfriend booked this place
on Airbnb for a week.
- hate to break it to you,
but I -- I reserved this Airbnb.
-What?
-Yeah, my friend
Jimmy hooked me up.
I-I booked the Airbnb.
I booked it yesterday.
-Oh, well...
we booked it on Sunday.
-Well, I don't know
what to tell you.
I signed for this yesterday.
I got an email confirmation
if you want to check it out.
-Please welcome to the show
Katie Holmes, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-You look lovely,
and I really want to stress
for everybody watching at home
right now that if we were
wearing our outfits that we have
on, outside in the New York City
weather right now,
we would be so miserable.
-Yes.
This is very much
the air conditioned studio.
Don't be watching at home
thinking, New York must be
nice and cozy right now.
No, it's real bad.
-It's real bad right now, yeah.
-This is very exciting.
This is the second time
you've directed a film?
-Yes.
-And I'm wondering, did you feel
more confident going
into it a second time?
-Yes, and also,
because it came --
we shot a year after lockdown.
And the movie takes
place during lockdown.
As actors, I think we all went
through that moment of,
are we ever going to work again?
Are we ever going
to be on set again?
So it was more about,
oh, my God, there's tape,
there's a mark,
we have lines, wow.
We can do it again.
So it was --
it was actually just --
it never gets easier because
there's always
something to figure out,
but it was definitely, like,
thank you, God,
for every moment, you know?
-It's nice.
I mean, I think everybody felt
very grateful to be able
to get back to work,
to some sense of normalcy.
But in order to, you know,
to start filming a film
a year into lockdown, that meant
that you were writing it
sort of right
at the beginning of it.
-Yes.
-I think some people felt very
creatively stifled at that time.
Did you very early on
in that time that we were all
spending alone think, "Oh, I'm
going to actually sit down
and try to write something?"
-I mean, pretty much, yeah.
I mean, I went through the,
you know, watching
a bunch of movies,
and actually during that time,
I was watching movies
that I grew up on.
Like "Manhattan," "Annie Hall,"
"When Harry Met Sally."
Like, movies that I knew
the ending,
it was comforting,
there was joy.
And so I thought, well,
I've been -- I was reading a lot
about, you know, couples coming
together, falling apart.
It was like, "I think with the
threat of the world ending,
let's see a couple
come together."
-Yeah, that's good.
So funny you say that.
I also feel like
in early pandemic
I only wanted to engage
with things where I knew
the ending, and it was --
you know, we were all
living this time where none
of us knew what the ending was.
-Exactly.
I was like, "I think
I'm gonna -- I am going to watch
"Moonstruck."
You know what I mean?
-Exactly, exactly.
And I watched that too,
many times.
-That a winner, right? Yeah.
-Ah.
-What kind of director
do you find yourself to be?
And do you feel like you
borrowed from the directors
you've liked over your career?
-Definitely.
I'm definitely...
I love actors, and some of the
best experiences
I had came from working
with Curtis Hanson,
Christopher Nolan and Ang Lee.
And then also doing
"All My Sons" on Broadway.
Just that eight-week
rehearsal experience.
I just felt so blessed
because these directors
all just took the time to help,
you know, create a character.
So I try to give my actors
and myself the space to create
the characters
and really play and improvise.
-You obviously
are an actor as well.
Are you hard to direct?
-[ Laughs ] Always.
I mean, every day
I struggle with that.
-Is it tricky, like,
when you're in a scene
with another actor and you're
also the director, obviously?
I mean, you're not the first
person that's had to deal
with this, but I feel like
the other actors in the scene
have to feel like
you're paying attention
to them the same way --
-And I am.
-Right.
-But what I didn't know
until today,
because I was doing interviews
with Jim Sturgess,
who plays Charlie.
-Who was in the clip there,
yeah.
-Yes.
He's like -- I forgot --
but he's like,
"Katie never yells cut."
And I forgot that, because
I like to sort of,
what else you gonna do?
You know?
And he was like, "Every day
I didn't know
what was going to happen."
I was like, yeah,
but that's the fun of it.
I mean, the script
is sort of just there.
So I guess I'm unpredictable.
-That's good.
-Yeah.
-That's a good thing
for a director to be.
You wrote yourself
as a food critic in this.
Do you think you would make
a good food critic?
Because I don't think I would be
a good food critic.
-Um, I would enjoy it.
I mean, I love Ruth Reichl
and I mean, going in with a wig
and that would be kind of fun.
-Oh, this is -- right.
I mean, that's a real --
-They can't -- they can't
know you're there, so you get to
disguise yourself.
-But I feel like...
I mean, what a great job.
-Yeah.
But I wouldn't -- I imagine
the best meal
you've ever had, right?
Would it be worse if you had
to wear a fake wig?
[ Laughter ]
Like, that would be my thing.
-I know, right?
I'd always be worried
my fake moustache
would fall into the soup.
-Exactly.
And do you have to pretend
it's not --
Yeah, you have to,
that it's not the best meal.
-Right.
-I'm not good at that.
-That's the thing.
I feel like most of the time
I'm just super happy
at a restaurant
like when the food gets there.
I feel like
if I was a food critic,
I'd always be like,
"Another a-plus.
I ordered it, I ordered it,
it came, I ate it."
-Yeah. Your -- your opinion
would probably --
probably lose the value there.
-How -- like, when you write,
who are the people that you
sort of show your work to over
the course of the process?
-My poor friends.
And I bug them
until they read it.
-Okay.
-Sometimes I make them read it
over the phone with me.
But yeah, for this, I actually
reached out to my friend
Dito Montiel, who did "Guide to
Recognizing Your Saints."
I love that movie.
And we worked together on
"The Son of No One."
And he helped me out a lot.
And then Derek Luke
and Jim Sturgess,
we wrote a lot of it together.
I mean, they signed on,
and then it was like, you know,
I do have some thoughts here
and some thoughts there.
I was like, "Great.
Let's do that."
-That's very nice.
You're very collaborative.
That's the right kind
of person to work with.
-Yeah.
I mean, I always think
that it's just, yeah,
it's going to make it better.
I don't know.
I mean, my ideas are fine,
but I'm sure --
I know there's a lot better
ideas out there.
-Do you like shooting
in New York City?
Because obviously
you've done that a lot.
-I do.
-Do you feel like New Yorkers
are excited
when they see something
shooting?
Or they're already over it?
-Most people
are already over it.
-Yeah.
-I always feel like in New York,
I think everybody
thinks they're a celebrity.
You know what I mean?
-Oh, yeah. Absolutely.
-Everybody thinks where
they're going
is more important
than where you're going.
-It's so true.
But I'm the exception,
because I'm always --
I get excited
when I see a movie truck.
-I do, too.
-I'm always like --
I try to find the one
person that might tell me,
because they're not supposed to.
-Sure.
-So usually they'll be like,
"It's a student film."
-I'm like,
"I've used that excuse.
Come on.
What is it, what is it?"
-Do you think they're like,
"Katie Holmes
is sniffing around
this movie set?"
-I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe I have a reputation.
-I walk by and I'm like --
I'll see trailers
and they'll have like a star
on the door but not a name.
And I want to walk up
and be like, hey, there's a high
likelihood I know
who's in there.
-Yeah.
-So why don't you go
tell them I'm here.
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's kind of --
it's kind of humiliating.
-It's really humiliating.
-Now that you mention it.
-Also there's times where
I'm walking by,
and I feel like --
even though I'm --
I feel like they somehow
think like
I'm there creeping
on the film set.
And I'm like,
what do they think?
That I'm like out
looking for guests?
Like --
[ Laughter ]
That I'm like, "Oh, we don't
have anybody for Thursday.
I'll go hang
around the trailers."
-Yeah, exactly.
You have the list of,
like, New York locations.
But for -- we did a movie this
fall called "Rare Objects"
that I also directed,
and we shot
like a block from where I live,
which was fantastic.
And we also shot up in Queens,
and so we --
it was a real love letter
to New York,
and such a great experience,
to, you know,
just shoot all over the city.
And -- and so, yeah, it was --
it was quite fun.
I mean, to go back
to your original, like, yeah,
I love shooting in New York.
-It's nice.
It is really nice to be able
to present New York City.
I mean, again, those movies you
were talking about early on.
You know, those are --
those -- a lot of those films
are the reason why
I wanted to come
to New York City
in the first place.
-Me, too.
-It looks really good
on a big screen.
Anything you can do to make
people -- remind people
what a great place
it is to come to visit,
especially at this weather.
-Especially, come now.
-You've got to come now.
-Yeah, come now. It's fabulous.
-Thank you so much.
Congrats on the film.
-Thank you.
-It's such a delight to see you.
You guys, that's Katie Holmes.
"Alone Together"
in select theaters
July 22nd and On Demand
July 29th.
We'll be right back
with Joe Pera, everybody!